in the fifth lesson we encounter some
very useful expressions which i just
want to touch on
the main emphasis of course is for you
to listen to the whole lesson and read
it and save words and phrases but i'll
just i'll just touch on a few of the
expressions here
the first one is salud
very very very commonly used greeting
you see someone that you know mind you
get used to saying it if you met the
person before
the next expression we is is tulum
all the world no it doesn't it can mean
all the world
but it normally means everybody so as in
many languages there are expressions
which if we translate them literally
don't really convey the meaning
means everybody so in the little text
here the person says
hello everybody hi everybody
another one is this sibu play which
comes up all the time it's please if it
pleases you is what it literally means
but it's
please and often abbreviated to svpc
play a key word or expression that you
need to learn
and finally
in this expression we see this
poliwhisay
do you speak french people are going to
ask you and you have to get used to
saying that we jourpal or jean-paulo
depending on how
confident you are in your french